Uh, we're gonna look at 27, uh,
28 and 29 today of Paradise.
Ah, three candles that,
uh,
really I think Dante Constructs
together and where Dante puts home,
puts forth this theory of
creation and cosmology tool,
which are not the quite the same thing.
A theater Beatrice that's
explaining the shape of the cosmos.
It's very difficult,
uh, three cancers. Um,
but it's done in such a way that, uh, uh,
there are two different things
you'd seem creation and,
and a physical description
of the customers,
which we call cosmology and they're
abusing the Dante's dealing with two forms
of the universe, a spiritual one. And the
physical one I'm going to show all of,
of,
of this is as we go over the
three cantos but I would,
I would like to argue that in effect
they are not quite the same thing,
but not really all that distinct.
There's a very tenuous line separating.
The two of them were, where are we first
of all in the, in the, in, in space,
we are somewhere in space.
Dante has gone past now. Uh,
the haven't really fixed
stars with, uh, the, the, uh,
the examination of the
three, uh, the three words,
the three terms,
the foundations of,
of things that we experience as trust
or we experience as existential hope or,
uh,
a love that if you combine it,
it's always implies always
not northern Canto 26,
but possibilities of
betrayal, uh, uncertainty.
Uh, so it, it, it,
it combines both a faith and
hope in a very programmatic way,
but Canto 27th and to
continues, uh, with, uh, uh,
in the, in the afterglow of, uh, the, the,
the fixed stars, Eh, and the candle.
Just to give you an idea about how,
what,
what formerly is happening here.
The first part of the Canto really
looks back formerly at Kantar 27 of in
fairness, there is clearly a parallel
between the two candles here. Dante,
you remember what he does?
He meets Saint Peter Actually,
who has been examining him.
But now after the examination of
the three theological virtues,
he goes on in a prophetic denunciation.
He denounces the collusion
between, uh, the,
his place. He says, my
place, it's the papacy,
the place instituted by, because
of him. He's the Peter, he's the,
the stone and his successors.
That's the way it sounds.
So the Canto literally looks backwards.
Uh,
and the parallel with human hair for
a number of parallels with, uh, uh,
in fair 19 where Dante meets,
are you remember the,
the pope's where,
uh,
turned upside down and the flames,
the kind of, the pattern of the,
of the Pentecostal fires?
I don't there the plants have their feet,
but this is more clearly a reference
to come to 27 of in fair where,
uh, this is the, uh, the
very beginning. This is a,
there is a him our canto 27 glory be
to the father, the son, et cetera.
And then, uh, uh, lines
40 and following, uh,
we have, uh, uh, this, uh, um, this,
this great,
great attack.
It was not our meaning 45 that are on
the right hand of our successors should
sit one part of Christ evil.
And on the other, on the left,
not that the keys which were committed
to me, it should become the device.
On a standard for warfare on the baptized
know that I should be the figure on a
seal for sold and lying favors for which
I often redden and flash with fire.
This is the fire of prophecy
without a doubt. But it's also, Eh,
retrospectively,
uh,
a reference to the attack against
the Barnabas who encountered 27.
We've be fair. No, it
showed as he is in, uh,
colluding with, uh, uh, the, the,
we do the Montefeltro you remember?
So there is a clear, uh, okay.
It's a clear symmetry
between the two candles. Uh,
I will,
uh,
has and to add that came to 27 is also
has a kind of castic structure because at
one point,
just to give you this as a
formal description of what's
happening here a little
later, um, after this outburst by Peter,
uh,
Beatrice and the pilgrim
move on to the next heaven,
which is around, uh, uh,
line 75 and following the next heaven
is the so called Crista lean heaven,
which is still material. He said the
boundary of the material universe,
it's still material, but it's very, uh,
exactly crystal light. It's a very, uh,
thin materiality, almost,
almost, but not quite spiritual.
It's also called the premium
more Beta because it's here.
This is the technical term that they
get it see that in, in this heaven.
Then we have problems of
origins, the origin of time, uh,
the origin of a space. Uh,
Dante goes on giving this,
Beatrice goes on giving this cosmological
description of the universe in
material terms, uh, and here
to continue with the formal,
uh, the, the, the question, the issue
of form. Now, uh, I one point B,
it says, wait, look behind you
so that you can have an idea.
You can measure the enormous distance
you have traveled from the earth.
He said the boundary of the material
cosmos, and you might say, well,
he's at the edge of the cosmos.
He's going to fall off.
And that it was always one
of the objections about the
idea of the finiteness of
the cosmos, which I believe
it or not, the 17th century,
we'll never really far off because the
university is, is fear. So the only,
the only place he has to go to
is, uh, is bad. There's no, uh,
literally edge.
Every point is the edge and every point
is in a continuous spherical curve.
But anyway, from the point of view, oh,
he said he's arriving there. So she says,
look back,
and what does he see?
And this is the line from the time when
I had listed on this is 27 line, uh,
75 from the time when I had looked before,
I saw that I had moved
through the whole arc.
That's the language of this
fear. Now, circle an arc.
It's just gives you an idea
of Ferris [inaudible], uh,
from the middle to the end of this rose
climb. So that I saw on the one hand,
beyond caddies,
the Med track of Ulysses,
she just sits the pinpoints that the
little place where you racist trespass,
the boundaries of the world,
of the,
of the Euclidean space he had a,
for which he has has been them, the
encanto 26 of infanticide, Suzy,
this is what we call a cosmos
and other one's 26 and 27.
We do see that 26 at our illusion, uh, to,
to Ulysses and Adam, right?
Which we talked about about, uh,
this figures and here in 27, uh, and,
and in 27 of her there is [inaudible].
And then in paradise 27,
uh,
there is this and there is also a kind of,
this is Ulysses.
So there's a sort of castic structure.
27,
paradise refers to the sex of
Paradise and refers also to 27 of,
uh, of, of inferno and
26 of [inaudible]. So,
and the question is, why does
Dante pinpoint, once again,
Ulysses he sees at the West the
point which you list his head,
uh, had trespassed and he
calls it they're mad track. Uh,
the math track of Ulysses,
uh,
clearly a counter Ulysses is still part
of this fascination that it exerts an
incredible fascination on the imagination
of the poet and the pilgrim. Uh,
my, like, you resist or am I going
to be lost now? Like you're racist.
But at the same time,
it's a way of hinting at
how much he has exceeded.
You. Listen, as adventure, he will.
This is only one pass the
pillars of Hercules. He,
Dante is now at the outer most boundary
of the visible physical universe.
So there's a way in which
there is a little bit of a
detachment and yet, uh, uh,
a constant fascination.
We tried to explain why he's so fascinated
with the results. At the other end,
he also sees,
and on the other nearly to the shore
where a roper made herself a sweet burden.
This is really the eastern part of
the, the, the known world Europe,
uh,
the rape of Europa by Jupiter so that
we really have a term and neurotic
transgression and an intellectual
transgression as if the two are now,
once again, are involved
in this, uh, in this, in,
in a Dante's vision as if he's now
coming to the point where knowledge and
desire really have to coincide.
He's come to the point where, uh,
the beautiful in the good are one
at the point where all of the great,
uh,
contraries and distinctions that we have
been pursuing all along merely have to
go on, are converging. Let
me continue with this idea.
This is before I go on
with what happens in, uh,
in the Canto Canto, uh, Dante
moves into the Primo Marbella,
which is the place where, uh,
this, I, I continue with this. The,
uh, uh, he goes on, um,
a lined 100,
um,
the goal into the swiftest part of heaven.
That's the premium mobile.
All motion begins from here.
Uh,
Dante is moving from what
would seem to be an ethical,
the ethical seen,
the denunciation,
Peter's denunciation of the abuses within
the church that's done in a prophetic
tone, but also from a
tone, a tone of ethical,
the ethical language.
Uh, he goes into the,
the so called premorbid,
which actually is
the heaven of metaphysics. You'll have
been telling you about the grammar,
rhetoric, music, geometry. This is
what we call the heaven of metaphysics.
And you know what that is, right? You,
you understand what metaphysics means?
It's a, um, Dante refers to
it as they did refer to it.
Harris total refers to it as the first
philosophy and the cold it first because
it rains rules supreme among goal,
the arts and all the sides.
It's the most important of
the sciences is the point.
It's the point of arrival of all the
sciences and it's cold first philosophy.
Um,
because it explains also questions of
origins and you'll see the language of
origins or the origin of time.
The original space creation itself,
the beginning of the world causes
foundations. These are the,
this is the Great Rome that
metaphysics discusses. Dan Can,
interesting thing is that in the Middle
Ages and Dante so connected with physics,
physics, he says a metaphysical
really go hand in hand.
One tries to give the explanation of
the physical world and McAfee physics,
the theoretical general rules.
In fact,
and this is probably where
I should mention this,
there are people who
believe that metaphysics,
metaphysics was not a term that
really indicated that anything,
uh,
really different,
a completely different from the, the,
the knowledge that physics provides,
they will say that was metaphysics.
Metaphysics was called
metaphysics because the,
the book was placed on the shelf a
little bit after the book on physics.
You see what I mean? It was really
more a way of defining the POC,
the place of the book. On the
library, so to speak. It's probably,
uh, but it was, was known as that,
but it's probably more of a
fiction then a than anything else.
The fact is that there is such a science
for Dante that deals with causes,
origins, beginnings, time, uh,
etc. One of the things are here
we have, it's uh, uh, the Dante's,
uh,
the Beatrice Psas describing line 100,
the nature of the university
as she plays the cosmologist,
which holes the center still
and moves all else around.
It begins here. So this is already
the beginnings. It literally,
the language of beginnings here
begins motion is Dante stands,
uh, uh, then at the boundary
of the physical universe.
And now she gives an explanation of
this. He said, he said, the boundary, uh,
and this heaven has no other hardware,
place questions,
but the divine mind, the real
beginning, the, the, the, the,
the real universe is in God's minds.
Okay?
So he distinguishes two worlds.
The physical world was he
and the spiritual world,
which is in God's mind in a way
and test to make it very simple.
Dante is journeying into the mind of God.
There is one man who had written a
text Bonaventure whom you have seen,
whom you have met before.
And he wrote this book called the
itinerary of their mind into God.
It is, uh, the way of trying to explore,
to enter mystically enter the mind of God.
Dante doesn't do it in a mystical way.
He tries to understand what's what's
beyond the physical world to give the
description of this universe.
This is the term that keeps reappearing
in the next three cantos light and love.
Enclose it in a circle as it does
the others and of the garden.
He that [inaudible] is this whole
intelligence, this premier mobility.
It really is a kind of a curve that
wraps up all the other heavens.
We have seen, this is the ninth heaven.
All the other heavens have been, uh,
uh, our, our enwrapped wrapped within it.
But it's not only a boundary, Dante views,
it is also the beginning of the
threshold for the spiritual universe.
Okay?
It's both the boundary of the physical
world and it's always also the,
so it goes like this.
This is the earth
and goes growing, et cetera. And
then when we come to the ninth,
hm.
This becomes at the same time,
yeah.
Uh, kind of convex and
concave a semi circle. I have,
believe it or not,
a shape of what I think is not this cosmo.
And here it is. This is a, this is, I'm
going to pass it around. This is a shell,
but it's actually really made it seem
cooler and found this would be the,
uh,
the it Auntie and they explain a,
there'll spirals really like, uh, um,
the f since Dante thinks of the cosmos
is a book and we will call it a cosmo
book. That's if that's a neurologist
that I coined here. Now, uh,
it kind of cosmo book the
book in the shape of a cosmos.
It's really a parchment or
rolled up within itself. Yeah.
You know what I parchments how
and medieval in medieval, uh,
in classical ideas of,
um, of the production,
the material production of books.
We have the ancient parchments,
which are all rolled up
well, like, like Ah, ah,
the term is around a steak and
then held together by a ring.
That's really the,
the shape.
It's [inaudible] production of books that
in the history of the book is Le later
replaced around the fourth century.
But this whole called Codex,
which we have for instance,
even in Binaca, a codex has, uh,
it's made of uh, uh, quartos.
It's made of folios and on divided
like a book today made of a,
ah,
ha would have quarters folios.
If you go and see the
Shakespeare's, uh, the, the, the,
the folios of Shakespeare in the
Erisa beaten club. For instance,
if they let you go in or you belong there,
take a look and see what f uh,
the, the, uh, they call x release.
[inaudible] seems to be combining
the two folds. But anyway,
you have an idea here of,
uh,
what the shape that I'm
trying to describe to you.
Is there a kind of, uh, um,
if you wish there are spirals,
a one following the other and next to it,
that is going to be a spiritual universe.
Now the universe,
which we'll come to in a
moment, so this is the, the,
the first description that she's giving,
the idea of the spirituality of space.
That's the one thing. The spaces
fair equal, uh, and uh, has,
has the premium mobility as a boundary.
And now we have an be a
discourse on explaining it's
motion is not determined by
another's. This is line one 12. But
from it, the rest of the measures,
everything begins here. This is, uh,
the physical beginning of the universe,
which we inhabit even as 10 from
half and the fifth. In other words,
it's as sure as it is the
two plus five make, make 10.
And how time should have its roots
in that vessel and in the others.
It's leaves,
may not be playing to the
even time begins here time,
uh, is understood then by
Dante. Uh, do you see what the,
is as a kind of a tree growing from a pot,
that part of eternity?
Uh,
he does not understand time
in a linear way. You know,
the guy has a beginning and an end.
It's not the wheel of time. You,
you heard or the wheel of becoming,
you may have heard this.
Have you heard this description about
the wheel of becoming in which this is a
platonic idea of time where all
things are contained. Dante,
things of a tree, a of time
as a tree. The roots are,
which are in the part of eternity and the
foliages are in reach us in reach into
our own world.
We are in the shadow of the tree of time.
We only see leaves that were fall because
this idea of the dispersion and the
falling of time, the passing of
time. So this is, uh, uh, the, the,
uh,
the definition of what happens in 27.
So she continues after a while
with this about once again,
the language of covetousness
and uh, and, and, uh,
moral language about,
uh, the, um, what, uh,
happens in, uh, in the world.
And we move on to Canto 28.
Just some tell you,
uh, I have not forgotten that we are
talking about Ulysses in a little while.
And uh,
so now it continues with a 28
deals with the angelic hierarchy.
We are now still in the premium mobility.
Um,
but we Dante's that seeing into the
other universe, the spiritual universe,
and he sees a university which is
adjacent to the physical universe,
uh, with, uh, inhabited by angels.
And so that their corresponding parts,
you have the nine planets,
the seven planets, Pacific
stars, and the crystal in heaven.
And now you have the nine olders of
angels and Beatrice will go on describing
the v, the three triads of
angels, angels, archangels,
Thrones, you know, the, this is the
language that comes from the Bible.
The old testament comes from Babylonian,
a pedant in Persian sources,
apocalyptic sources. And it
will not seem to be really, uh,
really terribly different from
that, from that, that tradition.
And here,
uh,
we have also another way before this
whole description of the angelic holder
continues.
And when I turned line 12,
let me just focus on this a bit and when
I turned again and mind were made by
what appears in that revolving sphere
to one that looks intently on it's
circling,
I saw a point distance.
So we are a deep at the boundary of the
universe and other universes of merges
into view.
And Dante only sees a point
which radiated alight.
So keen that the eye on which at
Burns must close for it's piercing,
piercing power. Uh, so once again,
a series of revolving spheres,
uh,
this universe is not the
projection of the other university.
They are separate and adjacent.
There are two hemispheres and
this is what happens in a,
in Canto 28,
28 and we go to Ken to 29 and I ask you
to see how the whole argument continues.
Beatrice has been explaining breathlessly
the whole question of angelic
hierarchy.
And by the end of Canto 28,
he sees a,
she even mentioned that the older,
actually it's Dante here who mentioned
that the older his ordering of angels is
how the hierarchy is very different from
the one of the pseudo dialyzers line
one 30.
He says,
this orders all gays above and so prevail
below the Laurel drone and all drove
to God.
And ionizers set himself as such a zeal
to contemplate this is the sooner the
United years who had written about
the angelic hierarchy and dance.
It goes on to say that he defers
from him, that he just, uh, his,
his idea of angels is a little different
from his and Pope Gregory's a statement
of his own intellectual independence,
uh,
both in terms of a theologian and in
terms of an ecclesiastical authority.
Um,
and then Beatrice finishes the description
of this higher meaning the sacred
order.
That's what the Greek word means.
The Sacred Order of angelic, uh, uh,
the, the intelligences, the
function is to impart motion, uh,
to this fears.
Their function is to move between
the divinity in human beings.
They are messengers.
They the keep their spiritual entities
and they keep moving between God and uh,
and,
and the human beings.
And then we went to canter 29 where
now the language of cosmology,
but the order of the
cosmos becomes creation.
And I want to to show
this to you however this,
this shift to the language of creation
is conducted in an extraordinarily
interesting way that wants to say that
Beatrice has been talking nonstop about,
we've probably been a touch of playfulness
about the angelic hoarders and then
she moves almost right without catching
her breath talking about creation cantor
29 but look how this shift from the order
of angels to the order of creation is
described.
This is the beginning of Canto 29 when
the two children of Latona covered by the
regime and by the scales both at once,
make a belt of the horizon.
As long as from the moment when the zenith
holds them balanced till the one and
the other changing hemisphere are
imbalanced from that girdle for so long,
her face illumined with a smile.
Beatrice kept silence looking fixedly
at the point that had overcome me.
What an extraordinary image.
Let's read it again. So we are,
make sure that we understand that
because I'm not sure that it's very clear
though. I think it's, I
can make it clear, but the,
let's look at this again.
When the two children of Latona
meaning the Sun and the moon,
that's really what he's saying.
Um,
he has to describe the fact that
Beatrice seems not to have kept quiet,
that she went endlessly
from one thing to another.
That's what I call the playfulness
of Dante's, uh, uh, thinking. Uh,
and he saying that there was,
this is the image that he uses is when
the two children of Latona a Paulo and
Diana, you know that the sun
and the moon were in the,
in the universe of those vantage using
mythical language. Look at the language.
First of all,
the two children are Latona myth covered
by the ram and the scales science both
at once make a belt of the horizon and
Arabic word meaning the boundary of the
heavens. So Science, scientific language,
as long as from the moment when
the zenith scientific language,
the mixture and balancing
of Science and myth, uh,
but also way of talking about the,
a balance that is as vanishing and
there's fleeting as it could ever be.
That's the point that there was silence,
but he could almost not even tell that
there was a break in Beatrice's speech.
This is where she is he saying,
uh, when the two children of, uh,
of Latona the sun or a Polo and the moon,
they, Anna, uh, along the horizon,
they seem to be aligned together
and are held together by the zenith.
This is the zenith, the highest point
as opposed to the neither. Right?
So this is the balance that he's
describing that kept in a violin,
in a balance, in a, in a,
in a ray equilibrium when they
appear team to be aligned together.
And that balance in equilibrium is,
is quickly disappearing.
What is he saying?
He's saying the ship almost wins,
didn't stop speaking and then she began
and she goes home with the theory of,
uh, of creation. I tell Nora
ask what you would hear for.
I have seen it.
There were every [inaudible] and every
quando center place I've seen at a point
where place,
space and time coincide not
to gain a good for himself,
which cannot be,
but that's his splendor shining back
might say I stay in subsystem and he said,
turn it to beyond time.
Beyond every other bound is priest him.
The Turner Rov revealed
himself in new loves. Uh,
I have to correct my good friend,
dear old friends and Claire because
actually Dante does not say,
uh, that uh, the uh, he says, uh, uh,
love the Turner love actually the
language he uses. I don't know the,
I hope you are other installation,
social use,
other translations that are luckier
opened itself in new loves open itself.
It's, I take this to be um, uh,
sexual language as it can be.
Found a new love in gendered,
you know, opened itself
into new loves. It's,
and then in fact it continues
not before they realize it.
We're in earth for until
God's moving upon the waters.
There was no before or after,
before God's creation.
The language is biblical from Genesis.
There was no before and
or after in the physics.
This is an illusion to Aristotle's physics
when we're Iris told her is to define
time. He says it's the measure. Uh,
we speak of time when there is an a
before and an after because this is really
what time is the measure
of motion of motion.
A regard for a before and an after.
Dante says that before this time of
creation, there was no such a thing.
There was a, there was that it could
not be distinguished before, uh,
in terms of a of time, there was no
such a thing as before and after.
And then he goes on just to continue
with his sexual metaphor, foreman matter,
United and separate came into
being that had no defect,
like three arrows from a three string.
Paul,
that question of creation as a coming
together of form and matter is here.
Describe this juncture with,
since the language of creation
takes place as an act of love.
That's the first thing Beatrice is saying
and creation comes through as passion
and love. Passion. It's
an opening up in love,
opening up in new loves
and it's as physical,
the language of creation is,
could it would ever be. It's as,
as in terms of the natural,
the language of natural
production and reproduction.
This is the context of what
she saying before and after.
It is a safe to heavy creation.
Creation is that which in introduces
introduces the possibility
of distinguishing between
a before and then after
introduces a difference.
That's, that's what, uh,
the,
the language of Beatrice is,
let me go back to the image
with which we started.
Dante
is wondering whether or not there was
any break in Barrett's reaches speech and
he says that they,
there was a break.
It was so fleeting as happens with
whenever the sun and the moon along the,
the line of the horizon are going to be,
are aligned together.
And it is as if they are balanced and
held together by a, the zenith above.
And that is such a fleeting moment
in the alignment of the stars.
Why this metaphor?
Not only his saying that,
but I think that is also
an illusion to be it to,
I'm sorry Francesca here in Canto
five did you catch it where he says,
ah, for so long her face illumined
with a smile be it is kept silence.
She,
she just kept kept on talking,
looking fixedly at the
point that had overcome me.
The point that had overcome me is clearly
an allusion to per only a point was
that overcame us. Francesca
says in Canto five. Okay.
That's also there's an
illusion to Francesca.
The question that I have to
answer that I raised with us,
why is Dante mentioning this to inferno
figures and framing his discussion on
cosmology creation?
First of all by talking about Ulysses
and now talking about or alluding to,
not even mentioning, but alluding
to Francesca, why this fit?
One Who wants to transgress and trespass
the boundaries of the world in order to
know the other one who chance dresses,
the norms of what is
allowed because of love,
knowledge and love somehow come into
play but they're in the inferno version.
What is he saying though with this image?
Why this is talked about Francesca,
the uh,
the sun and the moon aligned briefly.
What do you think he's saying?
It's not a rhetorical question.
Let me just,
what,
why do you think he would use this kind
of language immediately after Beatrice
goes on explaining the creation of the
world and the distinction between the
before and then after.
Why this metaphor,
but this long paragraph,
this image here,
anybody,
I think that Donthe is asking right here.
Is it possible to localize a break?
And he's saying,
if this is when we speak,
the thing seems to be continuous and your
justice in every syllable between the
sound and another,
that is always an interval.
So that was in the language of Beatrice
and that's what to him is the idea of
creation.
It seems to be there is the opposite of
creation will be determinative of the
world. Something which would be
that the universe is eternal.
It has no beginning and no identifier.
You Bilbray I think you'll tell
if the universe is eternal,
you have no differences in, in
inside it dump. It wants to say,
it seems to be a continuous,
uh,
the university was to
pay continues extension
without time. It kind of
return it, it goes on and on.
And yet it says when we speak
that you can identify the break.
There was however minute
there was a break between,
reaches a exposition about the angelic
holders and now the exposition that she
goes into about the,
uh,
about creation and why then the
other two methods for them. Now,
now it's time to answer the question. Why?
Talking to him through Ulysses and uh,
and Francesca, why you vote
those two images. Um, the,
I wish we could, uh, uh,
I have to keep that hanging a while
so can be become a little bit more
compelling. What I'm going
to tell you. So with it, uh,
[inaudible] now this is, uh, uh,
and this erase shines. This Dante,
Beatrice is continuing with form
and matter United and separate.
This is conjoined, impure,
pure, and conjoin. He says,
and this Henry Schein's into
glass or amber or crystal.
So that's from it coming to its
completeness. That is no interval.
So that a threshold,
a threefold creation flush into being
from its load load all at once without
distinction.
And it's beginning with it all that was
created and ordained for the spirit.
And these were the summit of the universe
in whom was produced pure act two,
a part NC and so on. So, uh,
the idea is that there is
a universal creation, uh,
the University of creation, which seems
to be very much like the physical world.
It's described in physical
terms, the terms of, of uh, uh,
the moon and um, sexuality, uh,
the cosmological language
in scientific terms.
And yet there is some kind of a difference
that is introduced without creation.
We will not have difference,
would not even have origins.
That's the language. Now,
why those two figures,
why you listen and um, uh,
Julissa's and, and, and, and, and
Francesca, you [inaudible] uh,
I think that what Dante's doing
finally is allowing us to see what the
world of inferno has to be seen as the
wilderness [inaudible].
We,
we only saw as a world rejected as a world
of evil and horror all of a sudden is
now retrieved as the best exemplar of
what we may come to know of the spiritual
world.
It is almost an imaginative redemption
that Dante goes into about the actual
idea of, uh, of her. He's implying.
And that could become
in many ways heretical.
But I hope to show you that
it is not that, that, uh,
the universe as it goes back,
it's one goes back to the beginnings.
Clearly,
the journey to the beginnings has to
be seen as a redemption of all that has
been falling away. Uh, let me just say
it in a slightly less tortures way.
They can be no redemption unless it
implies that the whole of evil is overcome
and destroyed so that even the world
of hell now appears all of a sudden,
as part of what we get to now about
the ultimate structure of the universe,
this seems to me to be the
real, uh, uh, lesson. They,
the underlying and powerful
message that Dante sending through,
uh, this three candles in
the habit of metaphysics.
Let me stop here before I move into the
next Canto Canto 30 and see if there are,
let me take the questions now
before we go on to the next candle.
Um,
I,
I could go back maybe and try to Redo
what I have been saying was it's uh,
uh, but then me see if you have some
questions and then, then we can do that.
Please.
He never says that. Let
me be very, very clear.
He never says it anywhere
are,
there is never an indication thematically.
There's everything else that I have
said I could find counterparts and the
thematic Dymatize in the sense that
it's becomes part of a conscious
articulation on the part of what
he knows and he theme attached.
He makes it a theme clear.
Never says that.
Um,
but the,
there are two implications though that
I'm drawing on in order to be able to
make the kind of statements.
The first is the very
idea of the cosmos as a,
as a sphere, right? And the
idea of the cosmo was his fear.
It really means that,
uh,
wherever you are going and
you are going toward God,
then you're going back to the beginning.
Everything else can go back to the
beginning because that's the form,
the shape of the cosmos. And I'm
joining out in publication about this,
this understanding of the universe.
The other reason is that there is such
a thing has a redemption and Dantes we
didn't read the Canto
Canto seven of paradise.
It's focused on redemption,
a new beginning.
That's what redemption means.
Redemption means that the cosmos can go
back to its beginning and be restored
and its original form.
If this is true or it could
very well be that, you know,
from that point we have the poem,
Lucifer is always going to
be stuck in his eyes forever.
There's no, no, no hint
that he can move. Even. Uh,
Francesca is always moving around
in, in, in vicious circles,
right by remembering and then lost
in the labyrinth of time. You know,
to her is she literally moves in time
memory or cannot think about the past
without, we moved by it and goes
back constantly about, around it.
Uh, Ulysses gets lost. Who knows
where there is no way for him.
He, he has no sense of a trace.
Even, even from this point of view,
I can go on understanding
that in, have, in, in, in,
in a can't where place matters.
Ulysses never had a sense.
I never had a sense of belonging anywhere.
That's the Arthur dislocation.
Nanga uh, kind of, uh, you know,
he doesn't have a family that holds him
back and the children of the kingdom,
Ithaca,
anything in cash just goes on moving.
That is the overt sense of the poem.
But there is this theology of redemption.
And I'm wondering whether Theology of
redemption does not entail necessarily
that there is a return to the beginning.
But I,
before I go on the with restating
some of this, I want to ask you to,
um,
because I think it's one of
the technique that Dante users,
which is really extraordinary. Can
you go to the beginning of Canto, uh,
that the famous image of Latona
when the two children of Latona,
um, beginning Canto 29, I did.
It would like to ask you to look
at the Italian a little bit.
I'm not going to read it
when I'm just going to read.
I'm going to ask you to look.
I want to read it though.
Uh, at the first word wonder, right?
You all see that and look at line.
That's really the problem.
What do we call rhetorically
the practices of the cancer?
The beginning of the candle
introduction again, go to line 12,
the last word.
Quando right.
Go to the first law. Back to the first
line. The last word in that line.
Latona. Latona. Okay.
The first two letters,
law,
go back to Canto two line 12.
I'm sorry. The first two letters.
La Joel, this cat, that's a cosmos.
The lines together and they will
meet exactly at the word hemisphere.
Emis Pharaoh. That's the
center. Uh, that's the, uh,
the hemisphere hemisphere means
that they are, it's half Emmy.
The Greek is the two half spheres.
The universe is two half
spears composing one. I,
I think Dante's placing
us at a cosmic crossroads.
He's tough. He's locating us. It's
telling us where we are first of all.
Okay.
But he's also telling us that this
universe has a kind of video cold and very
secret laws, that that poem is
the secret laws that regulated.
I'm really arguing then that
there is this subtext that is if,
if a radical redemptive
theology would only,
uh,
entail the absolute purification of,
of evil, oh, that the
universe will have to,
to really go back to this kind of,
um,
Pythagorean purity, but without
the phases and descends, you know,
this whole, you know what I mean? All
of you, this Pythagorean idea that the,
the uh,
the life of the universe
stretches for 360,000 years.
Did you ever hear about that? Uh, he has
this, he has, which I really liked the,
the days of the year, you
know, then the, the, the 365,
I think we have 360 thousands.
Uh, he has every 3000,
6,000 years, the university rotates
and goes back to its point of origin.
And then it,
that Kevin's starts again the age of gold,
the age of silver, the age of, uh,
the age of paper we would call
it. Now, let's say that it's,
that goes back in and then it
goes back to its origin. Uh,
that's not the way downtown, the
stains, the movement of the cosmos,
but he doesn't the, the,
the, he, he, he, he,
he does present this redemptive
event that makes the universe,
uh, return to its pristine,
uh, uh, purity. That's,
that's why I made that statement. Um, any,
any other points before I go back?
Cause I do think I should,
I should say all of a, what I said
before, uh, any other questions were,
can help me clarify this
various points I can, yes.
I'm sorry.
The incarnation,
the incarnation is the redemptive
events that allow, what means,
what is the redemptive event,
the incarnation that the,
that accorded redemptive events
that would make the, the,
uh,
a new creation.
A New Adam has come into the
world and the new Adam through,
uh,
the sacrifice is sacrifice
through the gift God gave.
Allow the incarnation because human
beings on their own will not be capable.
That's the, the theology
of redemption. Uh,
human beings on their own would not
be able to save and redeem themselves.
So that an intervention from God through
his son was made inevitable in order to
reconstruct and in order to bring out,
uh,
and produce that original
order of the cosmos.
And if that is true,
and it is true when you only have
to look at everywhere in the poem,
but Canto Seven of paradise,
that's really what it is,
an enunciation of this whole theory in,
in,
in the terms of, for those of
you who are Anselm, et Cetera,
then that implies that there must be
some kind of a general remaking of,
uh, of the world. That's, that's
uh, what I think the, the idea.
But nonetheless, this should not obscure
the fact that there is a, uh, kind of, uh,
uh,
parents juxtaposition between the
physical description of the world and the
spiritual description of the world.
There are two hemispheres and
yet they are connected. The,
the spiritual,
uh,
the creation of the experience of
creation is really the way of positing a
distinction or a difference
into the universe, into,
into the theory that the world is eternal.
They are two conceptions that operative
in the Middle Ages and they're really
represented by,
one is by our clients who is a theologian,
but he's also a philosopher. And in fact,
he could be called as the, the, the,
the writer who wants to make a
philosophical theology. He argues, no,
he's known for the famous Suma,
but he wrote a tract called
Suma against the gentiles,
not the summa of theology,
but summa contra gentiles where the,
he argues that the eternity of the world,
the,
the theory of the eternity of the world,
that he said that there is no creation.
Ah, he says, could be
philosophically demonstrate it,
but it could also be philosophically
repudiated. He says, you know, if he lost,
we can argue one side of it. Then
he goes on arguing, uh, the, the,
uh, that there is no way of thinking
of, you know, the usual questions.
Who created the creator? The kind of
the oldest, this, uh, this objections.
It says, however, there is a
theory, a view of creation, uh,
which is, uh, um, allowed and
it's possible on account of faith,
but it also allows for the
thought of freedom, origins,
beginnings,
uh,
etc. Bonaventure picks up some of these
that these ideas debated in Paris in the
13th Century and 1270, uh, in Paris,
that both of them are teachers at the
University of Bordeaux ventures has no,
this is untenable.
The idea of the eternity of the world
is absolutely untenable because if the
world were a terminal, then
we really would have, uh, uh,
no way of no real succession of
generations that would be endless.
Uh, uh, people who have been living before
us, there's no evidence for this, uh,
would be endless forms of etc. He holds,
he upholds the Thea of creation than
intervenes into this debate and says that
it is the effectively the physical
world and the spiritual world.
I really one continuous,
one complimentary to the other,
and yet there is a
difference between them.
And the difference between them is
the difference that he can find,
embed outreaches, speech, that
little point of time, that little,
uh, intrusion of time that distinguishes
between one sound and another sound.
Um,
but the spiritual universe originates
in the world of nature is a natural
production and reproduction.
All of God's love.
The physical world in
exactly the same way.
So there is a kind of symmetry.
This is not pro Plato's
are inverted universe.
The physical world is not Plato's
inverted world. It's adjacent to it.
It is a safe,
Dante discovers that there
are more dimensions to the
world that we see then the
what,
what medieval are cosmologists or
classical cosmologist had imagined.
Interestingly enough,
and I don't say this is a proof
for any of what I've said at all,
but there is a famous 19th century
mathematician by the name of Freeman,
a German mathematician.
I don't know how many of you
studied history of science. He was,
he's known among other things for
having been the mathematics professor of
Einstein while he went on with a team
of his students studying the scandals of
the divine comedy to find evidence that
in fact Dante had already a theory of
fourth dimension. That there is
the, the University of we was it.
And then there's another universe.
It is almost as if the full of books,
the folds of the parchments.
I'd exactly giving an idea of,
that's what [inaudible] wrote me the,
the,
an idea about what the actual structure
of the universe. Maybe having said this,
don't forget to turn back
to me, my shell, the, the,
the emblem of what I take.
Very good. Thank you. Ah,
so let me see if there's some questions.
If it goes, we can go on, uh, uh,
talking about some of these issues.
Please. I'm so lucky as to how
the reference to it was seasoned
and Francesca and these cancers relate
Beatrice's description of the University
of redemption back to back
to inferno and how, um,
a reduction of the universe necessarily
implicate including inferno as numbers.
Excellent question. And I, I
really welcome your skepticism.
The question is, uh, uh, about, uh,
how exactly do the figures
of Ulysses and Francesca,
uh, shed light on what's
happening here. And, uh,
is it really tenable,
uh,
that Dante's implying the dose that
they, the, the, the sinners are,
are going to be a redeemed,
saved, more or less? That's
yeah. And, and why, like,
why, why they're brought up,
how they fit into that explanation.
Good, good, good. I think that
that's, that's a crucial issue.
Uh, it's clear, it's interesting that
Dante should look at Ulysses and,
and bring up the image of
your races and Canto 27.
You find that interesting and that,
uh,
and Dante one can say Dante's really
unlike your races now, he probably,
he probably realizes how different he is
from your racists because your list is
when to [inaudible] he's,
he's implying how risky his own
enterprise may be exact. You know,
which we have seen before. Uh, Ulysses
was brought up in this journey,
in Canto with the meeting
with a dream of this.
Irene was a happening even
before in indirectly many other,
in some other cases, uh, 26 and
in to one of, in fairness, even,
uh, and, and maybe we could just
stop there as well. Dante still,
that's a kind of
retrospective fascination. Uh,
he's looking back and I'm
pinpointing that tragic moment.
Calls it the mad they're mad track
of Ulysses madness implies that he,
uh, this man had the,
violated the limits or limits,
including the limits of reason.
Okay. In this rational pursuits,
philosophical investigation of the,
of the world, the scientific, uh,
who wants to go into the, and I'm
peopled world to have experience. That's,
that's the key word for him.
And yet therefore,
that madness implies that he had been
delirious, had been now going off the,
the track. Okay. It's just
Dante, maybe I'm that for me too,
but maybe not. Maybe I'm really a little
safer now. I'm in the hands of Beatrice.
She's guiding me. So it's the way
of trusting Beatrice. So we could,
we could say that that is all true.
Uh,
and therefore I could even see an
element of a relief on the part of Dante.
We would even catch that the
relief is, uh, uh, that, uh,
his own adventure, uh,
diminishes the epic,
the Greek epic hero. You
know, really the very little,
he just went beyond the pillars of
Hercules. So we could stop there.
It happens all the retrospectively we
can see the story of Ulysses is also the
story of a metaphysician. Dante is
in the heaven room at the physics.
In what ways in the place of,
uh,
what does make the physics
deal with those with place?
There's with time and that we can
understand why you listen to in Canto 26,
he seems to be going from place to
place is the metaphor that distinguishes
Julisa sold. And Dante says
he's a failed metaphysician,
but we understand that he really
was going to the absolute,
it really was trying to go where I'm
going, man. And there is nothing else.
We stopped there. We'd go to be at
risk than to meat. Saw is talking to,
to uh,
is,
is listening to Beatrice in Canto 29.
And he's tying to figure out if it's
possible to think of a beginning how do
things, how, how,
if you have the eternality of forms
and you have the [inaudible] of matter,
it's very difficult to know how you could
really distinguish anything that goes
before from what goes after. There is no
such a thing as a before and an after.
He tries to localize time.
That's really the problem. Uh,
and to localize time, he
says that it really, um,
uh, Beatrice, uh, uh, looked, uh,
and the reminded him of the point,
there was a point of joy that
overcame him. Maybe it's alluding,
there's a languages that are
Francesca. Uh, so why Francesca?
Let me just explain it at one point,
maybe he's alluding twick case,
the two of them that he
remembers. It's, you know,
all sorts of very spiritual eyes. The
context that is never, never vulgar.
Maybe he just alluding to a case that had
been exchanging to, oh, maybe the will,
the desire, the long game to have a
case now exchange a kiss with her.
Um,
but one thing is clear that he's thinking
of Francesca is also kind of Meta
physician because that's where we are.
What is the metaphysics of Francesca?
But the physics of desire, first of all,
a desire that, uh, what does it mean?
The metaphysics of desire,
desire, but it's home definition.
We submit the physical in the sense that
it's always a moving beyond the objects.
It gains a,
because it burns up the various objects.
Today I want this book, then I want
another book, and then I want the car,
and then I want the library, et cetera.
That's the inflict movement of desire,
which is what we call a
metaphysics of desire.
So she's a metaphysician not only she's
a metaphysician, she lives in time.
So she's a complimentary for a
complimentary figure to Ulysses.
Ulysses is, you remember
I stopped at sales, uh,
I left behind me, Seville and
then I, et Cetera, et cetera.
Now Francesca instead says,
or how difficult it is to
remember the joys of the past.
I remember I was reading,
uh,
that day I began reading that day
I stopped reading a only a poet.
Who was that that overcame at that point
of time, a point of the book, et Cetera.
So maybe Dantes seemed really saying she
too is another failed with a physician.
I they would like to be where I am now,
both Francesca and Ulysses.
So we are bringing them to the
private place where Dante is,
they're looking for
the same thing is he's,
he's having now a conjunction of
time in the Turnitin space in time.
We'll be in Quando to see the
point when all things go here.
That's, that's, that's exactly where he's
looking. How do I make things go here?
Of course it's possible to thin,
you know,
one way of thinking of paradise and the
joy of the blessed is to go on thinking
that my joy suppose that are saved
and whether unlikely proposition,
my joy,
it's possible to to argue is
increased by it's sadistic.
The view of those were suffering.
So
mercifully I'm saying, you
know, to me it's supposed to,
it was improbable form of a, of beer
beatitude, but it's likely that you know,
seeing someone down trodden
and punish the right like that.
Be The dentist saying a hierarchy. I am
the neither. Neither like you racist. No,
like really Francesca.
I don't think that that's Dante though.
He's talking about cosmology and creation.
The older other within how this order is
an order of love and now he's coming to
know this order of love because now
knowledge is love and love is knowledge.
I think that by the allusion to them,
he's also saying that here on
earth you can grant me that.
That's what I said before and I think
that I'm not pushing it to the point of
unbelievability. The whole
argument becomes unbelievable.
I can stay here and say,
wow, now what he's really saying is that
I am here and I see how things go here,
but I know that sinful people on earth,
those who of us who live
in the shadows of time,
you know that this tree and we
had under the leaves of time.
Then I know that in a sinful way they
were trying to do and know what I now have
come to do and know I could substitute
and said, well, we're all happy.
There's no argument.
I think that that makes logical sense.
I can push it to the level, to
the point of absurdity, to say,
look,
maybe if this is true,
he's also saying not only
that day in a shadowy way,
in a dim way where I'm dissipating the
real happiness in the sinful modes,
the sinners,
but that may be they too.
If you move out of the
stacks is you know this,
this is not set in the
techs that they too will be,
are going to be taken and placed in the
bosom of Abraham where all the blessed
dwell. Maybe two. This is a, uh,
is it my wishful thinking I grandchildren?
It's probably wishful thinking,
but I do have the theology of redemption
behind me that stands as authored by
Dante in Canto Canto seven of paradise.
I restated the whole thing
and two minutes. That's good.
That's not bad. Thank you.
Other questions before
we go back to please?
Yes. Thank you. Can I comment
about Francesca and the,
uh,
that the fact that there is the
creation is given in sexual terms,
you know, that this is
love that opens itself. Um,
the opposites of two new loves and so on.
Uh,
the,
uh,
I can not help but,
um,
play a little bit of editemological
game too, by the way.
Cause this is the world of origins and
I, I don't want to lose you. I mean,
I know there is only one
class, but I don't want to
lose you. Of course. The only,
the way in which length is conveying
all the senses is by playing with
etymologies. We set the mortgage is
the science of the origin of words.
So let me give you only one.
You,
I corrected my good friends and
Claire in separable from May. I mean,
I'm never going to be training,
but I have to correct them because
he says reveal. That's what he did.
He said the, uh, the eternal love,
uh, revealed itself. He knew loved.
He's missing the,
the whole sexual language,
which is exactly the reason.
Thank you. Thank you.
It's exactly the reason why I think that
Francesca to who can arguably can be
saved. That's exactly the reason that
the lay, the term he uses is, uh,
is uh, pants from the Italian.
In Italian we call it a plea,
right? Very close to in
English we have the word April,
by the way, as an opening of
the, of, of the spring. Uh,
just to give you a sense in
its demolishing a comes from,
I believe that Latin,
which really means to generate,
to bring to light is a woman
brings a birth to light and life.
That's really the word.
That's the meaning of the word.
So it's a sexual in this productive
as it can be. Before I go back though,
to your question about how does that go
into, it just happened what Dante saying,
that creation is the sexual process,
a sexual experience,
which is exactly what Francesca also that
breaking the law and doubted that she
has been the hell, is she going
to be in hell? Is she going,
are we going to understand that there is
a possible continuity between what she
did in the physical sense? And what
Dante is doing in a spiritual sense,
but this is the whole point of the
discussion on cosmology and creation that
there is some kind of continuity between
the two modes. Not Quite the same thing.
Of course creation is a different
order of experience that he said thin,
very thin line.
It's like a little breath of breath that
Francesco can release a c or Beatrice.
So call on talking endlessly
that she too would have.
That's the difference between the two.
So between the language of sexuality of
physicality and in fan and the language
of spirituality here in paradise,
the line,
there is a continuum between them
and there is a little difference,
but there is also a
possibility of a continuum.
That's exactly the argument that I,
I would make about that.
Let me,
they'll tell you more in a
historic way and up, uh, uh,
historical so that if you
don't agree with what I said,
so be it. Don't worry. The,
I don't agree with are completely
on my own, but the, the,
I think that there is a,
that's a radical reading of the
notion of cosmology and creation.
In Dante.
But let me tell you something
else historically where
it's done for taking these
ideas from
whenever you read commentaries on Dante.
And I hope that some of you will go on
reading and reading also our scholars.
Thank you critics. I I see
that nodding. It just, uh, uh,
my heart's just this gladdens when
I see that and they will tell you.
And I indicated that tool that you know,
that Dante is some kind of Aristotelian,
and that was talking about
metaphysics. How, uh, how,
how are they stole it or cause it first
philosophy and also in terms they never
tell you what the actual
sources of Dante are.
The sources of Dante about cosmology and,
and a small graphy really
neoplatonic the idea of creation.
Um, so especially with one
text that I have to mention,
this guy who writes the cosmo graph,
we are called a 12th century man.
[inaudible] Sylvester,
a Frenchman,
Bernard Sylvester who writes
yes.
Cosmograph yet 12th century,
uh,
known as the author of the
School of shout. By the way,
this text is what available to Dante.
Uh,
we have a text of this man.
Cosmograph yeah,
one copy only because a Florentine later,
let me say in Florida, but in my book
capture some of you know very well,
he copied it down and transmitted to us.
We know his handwriting because
we have his text. So we,
we know this is 1340.
Dante of course wrote 1302,
but clearly the Texas
available that in this text,
Bernard give us an idea of
creation and cosmological ideas,
physical ideas.
They had been reading the time he is in
France and they were always surprised
and wondering what is the difference?
How can we go on having,
having pleat or say one thing
about creation and geneses
saying something else.
How were we going to connect
this to this two forms,
this tool, uh, sources of, of,
of a traditional and authority.
And they, when they
argue, when he goes on,
Tony's talks about the idea of
a preexisting world of matter.
That natural world, uh, and,
and the malignant materiality and how
this malignant materiality is subdued into
shape and subduing into shape
is always sexual language,
not to Hra is that which produces,
generates,
this is the text that I believe stands
behind Domtar's a physical explanation of
a universe which is physical,
but at the same time it
is not just physical.
There's also a theory of creation
and it's the theater of creation has
unpredictable possibilities is it tells
you the things can be renewed if you
stayed within the bowel.
You see how he criticizes the
physical conception of the world.
If you stay within those boundaries,
you can't expect anything other
than what you already have.
You cannot expect any more evil or
any less evil than what you already
experience.
The only idea,
the only people that way in which human
beings can think about renewal can think
about change of free them up or origins
is only within the context of creation.
That's exactly Dante's argument.
And that's the profound
justification for the,
for the distinction between one,
uh,
older of experience at the
different order expats.
But if this is true and
it is true for Dante,
then I have to take also
seriously this idea of, uh,
this,
the central event of redemption,
which now we understand where he
takes that. To me, the moment,
the experience of the incarnation,
this is exactly,
it follows the four if he has to,
if he believes that there is such
a thing as Andy does creation,
than he has to believe that there's
is also the idea of a re create a re a
second creation.
There's the first creation clearly
didn't work out all that well.
So there is this other possibility
please
the sense that in these lines at the
beginning of 29 that we've been talking
about,
that Dante is,
is very aware of being on theological
in the ice skating close to the danger
line.
The idea is that divine love
spills over into a creative
so that
it can be reflected back and adored and
loved in return the way that Paolo and
Francesca,
um,
that's not far from before
that before creation,
God has everything, but it's
still a little low to me. And, uh,
and that suggests a kind of imperfection
or at least in completeness,
but how can God,
this passage by saying, uh, uh,
not to acquire new goodness for himself,
this is in the legislation,
which cannot be perfect because of that
he wants to announce before he offers
his neoplatonic vision of the
relationship of the God had to creation.
He wants to signal his orthodoxy to
doubters who might hear in this something
which is less than perfectly
Christian because it, it,
it comes close to the,
of an, of an, of an,
of a needy God or a God who in the way
that every lover needs something and
other to love in return is
in a predicament and creation
is the solution to the
predicament that God is in
before the world is made.
The question is that we're actually,
cause it was more of a common,
uh, uh, by the Mastro here, the,
the, uh, the comment is that Dante
seems to be on a theologically
risky thing on thin ice.
I'm quoting thin ice because,
uh,
the notion of a god who are
really trying to,
uh,
save his skin as it were
by claiming a kind of, uh,
of theological orthodoxy when he
actually knows that the very notion of
creation, uh, whereby
God opens up into new,
into new loves.
It seems to imply that before creation,
God was a lonely guy. Uh,
looking for a partner,
some kind of, uh, Adam Adam in the
garden replaces that. That's really the,
the question.
I um,
I think that's a very interesting
idea of course, but I have to,
or two I would respond this
not an entirely in a funny way,
but I hope it will come
out. There's funny, uh,
it's really the,
it's really the question that synth
Augustan asks in the confessions.
You know,
there are always those people wonder,
cause that's really what the question is.
What did God do before creation
and since I gas in response,
he was busy preparing health to people
like you who ask this kind of this kind
of questions. And that's it. The,
but the the most seriously.
The idea is that indeed creation implies,
I mean,
that's a response that I would offer
creation in price, a big healing,
but this creation has been
going on forever and that
the idea of the Trinitarian
God is really a response to this problem.
You have,
you obviously, I think it's not
obvious, but to me it's more obvious.
I think that you are appealing
to a different theological
paradigm of where the
unity of God can be. The the,
the loneliness of God, the,
the Christian reading of that unity is
there is always a productive in internal
life of love. They're always goes on,
producing itself and improve itself.
On that note, to feel logical, grand
jury, I thank you and I say, thank you.
We'll see you have a good thanksgiving.